60 plaies sur le corps de la victime
retrouvé en marche de la Guinguette de
Valère c'était en 2019 le meurtre de
cette femme habitué du parquet avait
marqué les esprits celui qui était alors
son ex-compagnon comparé depuis ce matin
devant les assises d'Indre-et-Loire le
septiagénaire au cours la réclusion à
perpétuité Léa Turquie
il y a une certaine fierté d'avoir
débarrassé le monde de Caroline ces mots
se sont ceux d'une des expertes
psychologues après entretien avec Franck
accusé de meurtre sur son ex-compagne
une première journée de procès dédiée à
mieux comprendre qui il est il a 66 ans
au moment des fées un casier judiciaire
vierge et a été insérée
professionnellement toute sa vie la
course est penchée sur les comptes
rendus psychologiques et psychiatriques
l'homme est dépeint comme volubile
éparpillées dans ses explications et
surtout avec un rapport de supériorité
envers les femmes il adopte une posture
de sauveur avec la victime comme s'il
n'avait pas eu le choix de passer à
l'acte il a tendance à dire des choses
qui le desservent mais il faut
comprendre il faut prendre du recul et
pas tout prendre au premier degré et
qu'on comprend qu'il s'agit un peu d'un
mécanisme de déni pour se protéger que
peut-être la gravité des faits est trop
difficile pour lui le féminicide eu lieu
dans la journée du 31 mars 2019 à la
Guinguette de Valère Franck croise son
ex-compagne Caroline revenant à sa
voiture une dispute éclate l'accusé
explique se sentir nargué par sa
présence qu'elle n'aurait pas dû être là
sous les yeux de plusieurs témoins
Franck Hassen de nombreux coups de
couteau à son ex-conjointes puis prend
la fuite une soixantaine de plaies sont
présentes sur le corps de la victime une
après-midi sanglante qui l'aborde
aujourd'hui avec simplicité et
détachement ce mardi de nombreuses
participent sont présentes et
principalement la famille de la victime
je pense que la première chose qu'espère
les victimes c'est d'être entendu dans
la douleur qu'elles ont pu avoir d'abord
par rapport aux circonstances de la mort
qui sont terribles une victime qui a
beaucoup lutté pour pour survivre le
procès continue jusqu'à vendredi
notamment avec l'audition des témoins
l'accusé en cours la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité